A quick warning, there are curse words that are unbeeped in today's episode of the show. If you prefer a beeped version, you can find that at our website, thisamericanlife.org.
小提示：今天节目中会有未经消音的脏话。如果您更喜欢消音版本，可以前往我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org 收听。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. I recently heard this podcast that was so exciting to hear, because it felt like the people who did it invented something completely new, which is so rare. And it's like, I feel like they took what shows like ours do, and then just pushed it further and further until it became something else.
来自芝加哥 WBEZ 电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我最近听了一档播客，听的时候感到非常兴奋，因为感觉制作这档节目的人发明了一些全新的东西，这在当下非常罕见。感觉他们汲取了像我们这类节目的精髓，然后不断将其推向极致，直到它变成了某种全新的东西。
And I want to play you some of that show today. It's by somebody who I had never heard of before. His name is Sayre Quevedo. And the series is called Reaching Out. It's made by Futuro Studios. And as you'll hear, at some point years ago, it seems like Sayre started recording nearly all of his personal conversations, including these especially passive aggressive conversations with his twin brother that get more interesting and complicated the further you get into the series. And it's just-- I don't know-- real, messy life captured on recordings in a way that is rare to hear.
今天我想播放一些该节目的片段。作者是一位我此前从未听说过的人，他叫塞尔·克韦多（Sayre Quevedo）。该系列名为《接触》（Reaching Out），由 Futuro 工作室制作。正如你接下来会听到的，几年前，塞尔似乎开始录制他几乎所有的私人对话，包括那些与他双胞胎兄弟之间特别带有被动攻击意味的对话，这些对话在你越深入了解该系列时就越显得复杂且有趣。那真的是——我不知道该怎么形容——在录音中捕捉到了真实、混乱的生活，这在当下非常罕见。
And then Sayre also invented this way to do narration that at first, when you hear it, you're like, what's happening? And then-- I don't know-- I really came to love it. And the show is ambitious. I don't know if I've heard another podcast that tries to capture a person's life as completely as this one does, and just what it feels like to be alive right now. So we're going to excerpt some of the show today. That's going to be the whole hour. And I just want to say, stay with it. I guarantee, it pays off. Here's Sayre.
此外，塞尔还发明了一种叙述方式，起初当你听到时，你会想：这到底是怎么回事？然后——我不知道——我真的开始喜欢上了它。这档节目雄心勃勃。我不知道是否还听过另一档播客，能像这档节目一样如此完整地捕捉一个人的生活，以及此刻活着到底是什么感觉。所以今天我们将摘录该节目的一些片段，这将占据整个一小时的节目。我想说的是，请坚持听下去，我保证这非常值得。下面是塞尔。
On February 15, 2020. Connor calls you to ask if you want to look for your birth father. You do not record this conversation. This is notable, if only because so much of your life has been recorded, moments far less consequential than this-- you and Connor's fourth birthday--
2020年2月15日。康纳打电话给你，问你想不想寻找你的生父。你没有录下这段对话。这一点很值得注意，哪怕只是因为你生命中有太多时刻都被录了下来，那些远不如这一刻重要的时刻——你和康纳的四岁生日——
You earned a rubber nose. Can you guys say that? Then hand me a rubber nose.
你赢得了一个橡胶鼻子。你们能说一下吗？然后递给我一个橡胶鼻子。
A school performance-- you play a scared rabbit. Your only line--
一场学校演出——你扮演一只受惊的兔子。你唯一的台词——
I think we're lost.
我想我们迷路了。
Don't worry. We'll just go back the way we came.
别担心。我们原路返回就好了。
Which way did we come?
我们是从哪边来的？
A house party when you were 16, when you first began to record yourself.
你16岁时的一场家庭派对，那是你第一次开始录下自己的声音。
So I interview people and I talk to them about whatever I want to talk about. And since it's about me and it's about the things I do, I figure I should record this.
所以我采访人们，和他们谈论任何我想谈的话题。既然是关于我，是关于我所做的事情，我想我应该录下来。
There is a price for what we choose to remember and what we choose to forget. If you had known how this would all turn out, maybe you would have recorded everything. Or if you had known the cost, maybe you would not have recorded anything at all. On February 15, 2020, your brother calls you to ask if you want to look for your birth father, but there is no record of that call. There is, however, a recording of the call you make a few days later.
我们选择记住什么和选择遗忘什么，都是有代价的。如果你早知道这一切会如何收场，也许你当时会录下一切。或者如果你早知道代价，也许你根本就不会录下任何东西。2020年2月15日，你兄弟打电话问你想不想找你的生父，但那次通话没有记录。不过，几天后你给他回的那个电话确实有录音。
[PHONE DIALING]
[电话拨号声]
Hello?
喂？
Hey, brother.
嘿，兄弟。
Hey, what's up?
嘿，怎么了？
Nothing. My phone is at 10%, by the way.
没什么。顺便说一下，我手机只剩10%的电了。
Oh, that's cool. I don't feel like talking on the phone very long. I'm tired.
哦，那挺好的。我也不想在电话里聊太久。我很累。
I'm recording. I hope that is OK.
我在录音。希望没问题。
Oh, really? OK. Hmm.
哦，真的吗？好吧。嗯。
Yeah.
是的。
All right, that's cool. Are you recording because you want to talk about dad stuff?
好吧，那挺酷的。你录音是因为想聊爸爸的事吗？
Yeah, well, not just because of that, but yeah. I thought that's what you wanted to talk about.
是的，嗯，不只是因为那个，但确实是。我以为那是你想聊的事情。
I have other things on my mind, but hmm, I mean, yeah, that's just a very intense conversation. Can I tell you something crazy that happened today that has nothing to do with him?
我脑子里还有别的事情，但是嗯，我的意思是，那是场非常激烈的对话。我能告诉你今天发生的件疯狂的事吗？跟那个人没关系。
These days, you rarely know where Connor is until he's already there. You call, and he's in Washington with his girlfriend. You call again, and he's barely got service. He's trimming weed in Arcata. Or he's hopped a train to the Midwest. Or he's crashing on a friend's couch in Oakland. Right now, Connor is partying in New Orleans with his girlfriend. Right now, you are pacing around your room in Harlem, staring at a whiteboard where you have scribbled a list of vague to-dos.
这些日子，你很少知道康纳在哪，直到他已经到了那里。你给他打电话，他在华盛顿陪女朋友。再打过去，他信号微弱。他在阿卡塔修剪大麻。或者他跳上一列火车去了中西部。或者他正借住在奥克兰朋友的沙发上。此时此刻，康纳正和他的女朋友在新奥尔良狂欢。此刻，你正在哈莱姆区的房间里踱步，盯着白板，上面乱涂乱画着一堆模糊的待办事项。
Today, me and Claire were walking to go get my bike, and we walked by this guy who apparently used to live here. We keep walking, and all of a sudden, I hear steps, and I look behind.
今天，我和克莱尔走去取我的自行车，我们路过一个以前住在这儿的人。我们继续走，突然，我听到脚步声，我往后看。
Connor does not like it when you point out your differences, but contrast is the rightful and unavoidable dominion of twins. There are superficial distinctions, the kind of differences strangers point out when you inevitably pull up a photo of Connor after they learn you're a twin-- your tightly coiled curls, Connor's loose, wavy hair; Connor's growth spurt at 16; you're 5' 7, which you say is 5' 8. But nothing makes you feel more different from your brother than when he tells you these kinds of stories.
康纳不喜欢你指出你们之间的差异，但对比是双胞胎理所应当且不可避免的领域。有一些肤浅的区别，比如当你告诉陌生人你是双胞胎后，他们不可避免地调出康纳的照片时指出的那些差异——你紧卷的卷发，康纳松散的波浪发；康纳16岁时经历的生长突增；你身高5英尺7英寸，虽然你说你5英尺8英寸。但当他告诉你这些故事时，没有什么是比这让你感觉和你兄弟如此不同的了。
And I turn around, and the fucking guy is a block away from us--
我转过身，那个混蛋离我们就一个街区远——
Whoa.
哇。
--and just had fucking these knives in his hand and polishing his knives on his shirt and looking at us.
——他手里拿着刀，正在衬衫上擦拭他的刀，盯着我们看。
The critical difference between you and Connor is this-- long ago, without realizing it, you chose a kind of freedom, the kind that imparts stability and safety, and that you pay for in unsubsidized loans, quarterly job reviews, happy hours with coworkers, boring party conversation, conferences with field practitioners, mid-century modern furniture, boxing classes, and dental checkups. And Connor chose a kind of freedom that comes with land projects, one-off jobs at biker festivals, wide-open mountain ranges from the Union Pacific line, and that he pays for in a persistent smoker's cough, weeks on remote weed farms with Phish fans, and being pursued in New Orleans by a guy with a knife.
你和康纳之间最关键的区别在于——很久以前，你不知不觉地选择了某种自由，那种能带来稳定和安全的自由，你为此付出的代价是未经补贴的贷款、季度工作评估、与同事的欢乐时光、无聊的派对闲谈、行业会议、中世纪现代风格家具、拳击课和牙科检查。而康纳选择了一种自由，伴随着土地项目、机车节上的临时工作、从联合太平洋铁路延伸开来的广阔山脉，他为此付出的代价是挥之不去的吸烟者咳嗽、在偏远大麻农场与 Phish 乐队粉丝度过的几周，以及在新奥尔良被一个持刀男子追赶。
It was just like psycho ass move. So yeah, that was crazy. That's why I was talking to you.
这简直就像那种精神病般的举动。所以，嗯，太疯狂了。这就是为什么我跟你说这个。
Your brother thinks you are a judgmental normie, and you think he is a judgmental hobo. This is the shared cost of your divergent freedoms. You both pay for your choices with the degree of distance it puts between you, but you do love each other, and you are trying to be better, to be nicer, to be closer. This routine of phone calls, which began a few months ago, is your attempt.
你兄弟认为你是个爱评头论足的“正常人”，而你认为他是个爱评头论足的流浪汉。这是你们各自不同的自由所共同付出的代价。你们都用彼此之间产生的距离感来支付各自的选择，但你们确实相爱，并且都在努力变得更好、更友善、更亲近。这种几个月前开始的通话习惯，就是你们的尝试。
Drink water and eat meals.
多喝水，按时吃饭。
Yeah, we have a house.
是的，我们有房子。
All right, I love you.
好了，我爱你。
We can cook and stuff. All right.
我们可以做饭之类的。好的。
Yeah, I know you're not--
是的，我知道你不是——
I'll see you later.
回头见。
--eating over a trash fire. OK, I love you.
——在垃圾火堆上吃饭。好的，我爱你。
OK. There's nothing wrong with that.
好的。那没什么问题。
You do not return to the subject of your birth father tonight. There are no records of phone calls with Connor that week or the next. You assume his impulse to look for your father is a passing one. You doubt you follow up.
今晚你们没有回到关于你生父的话题。那一周或下一周都没有与康纳的通话记录。你认为他想寻找你父亲的冲动是一时的。你怀疑你是否会跟进。
You went through your phase, of course-- the one that you imagine most fatherless teenagers go through-- in which your father's absence took on an outsized significance, in which your adolescent brain dissected and disassembled its meaning in relation to your sense of self. Was your fatherlessness why you felt so apart from others? Was his abandonment a sort of permanent wound on your psyche? Only one way to find out-- write a lot of shitty poetry.
当然，你经历过你的阶段——你想象中大多数没有父亲的青少年都会经历的阶段——那时候你父亲的缺席显得意义重大，你青春期的大脑解析并拆解了其对你自我意识的意义。你感到与他人格格不入是因为没有父亲吗？他的遗弃是否对你的心理造成了某种永久性的创伤？只有一个方法可以弄清楚——写一堆烂诗。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
None of those poems are recorded, thank God. But one vestige invested remains-- a play about two boys waiting to meet their father at a cafe. You wrote it when you were 17. It was called-- perhaps a little overprecisely-- "Waiting to Meet Your Father" and was haltingly, painfully acted out by two fellow art students.
谢天上帝，那些诗都没有被录下来。但留下来一个残迹——一部关于两个男孩在咖啡馆等待见他们父亲的戏。你17岁时写的。它叫——也许有点过于精确地——《等待见你的父亲》，由两名艺术系同学结结巴巴、痛苦地演了出来。
What if he doesn't show?
如果他不出现怎么办？
He will.
他会来的。
And if he doesn't?
如果他不来呢？
I'll be OK.
我会没事的。
The central tension of the play is that the two boys are waiting at a cafe to meet their father, who they've never known, but he is running late, or maybe he is standing them up. The brothers argue about whether or not they should wait to find out which one it is. One boy is sure it won't be worth it. The other is adamant they stay.
这部戏的核心冲突是，两个男孩在咖啡馆等待见他们从未谋面的父亲，但他迟到了，或者可能他放了他们鸽子。兄弟俩争论是否应该等下去以弄清楚是哪种情况。一个男孩肯定那不值得。另一个坚持要留下。
Do you think about him a lot?
你经常想他吗？
No. Do you?
不。你呢？
Well, sometimes, like when we're about to fall asleep. It's usually while I'm not thinking that I think about him the most. It's one of those things where when my mind is just drifting, I'll suddenly start wondering about him, and then I'll have to make myself do something to take my mind off him. The more I think about trying to think about him, the more I end up thinking about him.
嗯，有时，比如当我们快睡着的时候。通常是在我不去想的时候，我反而最常想到他。这就是那种当你思绪漂移时，突然开始怀疑他，然后你不得不强迫自己做点什么来转移注意力的情况。你越是刻意去想如何去想他，你最终就越是会想到他。
In the end--
最后——
Let's go.
走吧。
Are you sure?
你确定吗？
Yeah.
是的。
--their father arrives a few moments after they walk out the door.
——在他们走出门口几分钟后，他们的父亲到了。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
You turn 20. On the eve of this new decade of life, you decided it was not worth it to actively think about your birth father anymore. It was not cool to still feel hurt about it. And so you could choose to feel nothing, and you plan to continue to do so now. You will not sabotage your brother's efforts, but you will not help them either. So you do not follow up with Connor about looking for your father. And Connor does not call.
你20岁了。在这个人生新阶段的前夕，你决定不再主动去想你的生父是不值得的。因为这件事仍然感到受伤并不酷。所以你可以选择什么都不感觉，并且计划现在继续这样做。你不会破坏你兄弟的努力，但你也不会帮忙。所以你没有再跟进康纳关于寻找你父亲的事。而康纳也没有再打电话。
But there are also no records of other calls either. If you had recorded everything, you would hear three sessions here with your new work-subsidized tele-therapist, the first an intake session, a concise, summarized biography of your life as it relates to your inner problems. You make radio documentaries. You won some awards for this last year.
但也没有其他通话记录。如果你录下了一切，你会在这里听到你与新的单位补贴远程治疗师进行的三次会谈，第一次是评估会谈，简明扼要地总结了你的人生及其与内心问题的联系。你制作广播纪录片。去年你还因此得了一些奖。
Whew. Wow. Hold on, one second. There are two parts to this speech, and I was going to keep it short, but what the hell, I got gold, so yeah. [LAUGHS]
呼。哇。等一下，一秒钟。这个演讲有两部分，我本来想长话短说，但管他呢，我拿到了金奖，所以是的。[笑声]
[CHEERING, APPLAUSE]
[欢呼，掌声]
You crave the attention and acknowledgment, and it also repulses you. You work at the most famous newspaper in the world at one of the biggest shows in the country. Lately, you've been leaving early to see if anyone notices. They don't.
你渴望关注和认可，但它也让你反感。你在世界上最著名的报纸和国内最大的节目之一工作。最近，你一直提前离开，看看有没有人注意到。他们没有。
Ah, alligator!
啊，鳄鱼！
You were raised by a loving single mother in the Bay Area.
你在湾区由一位充满爱心的单身母亲抚养长大。
Yikes.
天呐。
Alligator.
鳄鱼。
Yeah, you've got to be careful. There's alligators here.
是的，你得小心。这里有鳄鱼。
You would hear yourself tell your tele-therapist that your birth father left before you were born, and you've never met him, that you suspect based on nothing more than an elementary understanding of Freud and a few Instagram therapy videos that this is the root of some of your problems-- daddy issues.
你会听到自己在电话里告诉远程治疗师，你的生父在你出生前就离开了，你从未见过他，你怀疑——基于对弗洛伊德最基础的理解和几段 Instagram 心理疗法视频，这正是你某些问题的根源——恋父情结。
You have a twin brother, but you're not identical. You probably make the same joke you always do, that you're sorry to disappoint your therapist. People are always more excited when they think there's some other version of you out there.
你有一个双胞胎兄弟，但不是同卵。你可能会开你一贯的那个玩笑，说你很抱歉让你的治疗师失望了。当人们认为外面还有一个版本的你时，通常会更兴奋。
Most relevant to your tele-therapist, what you would like to fix about yourself-- it is mostly one thing, which you are almost embarrassed to admit-- you have the sneaking suspicion that you will never fall in love. Your last attempt officially ended the night of your 27th birthday, you and your ex shouting at one another beneath the rattling viaduct of the M line, your ex saying it's been two years. You need to get over me. I got over you in a week. I know, you said, I know-- even though you didn't know.
对你的远程治疗师来说最相关的是，你想修补自己的什么——主要是一件事，你几乎不好意思承认——你有一种隐秘的怀疑，你永远不会坠入爱河。你的最后一次尝试正式结束于你27岁生日那天晚上，你和前任在 M 线铁轨下嘎吱作响的桥下大声争吵，你的前任说已经两年了。你需要放下我。我在一周内就放下你了。我知道，你说，我知道——尽管你根本不知道。
That is as far as you get. Your therapist calls it quits at the start of the pandemic. You build fortresses of routine to keep the mania of your confinement from creeping in. You quit smoking, start running. You record your phone calls. You tell yourself it's for a project you hope to make one day about this historic moment.
这就是你所能达到的极限。疫情开始时，你的治疗师退出了。你筑起日常生活的堡垒，防止禁闭带来的狂躁潜入。你戒了烟，开始跑步。你录下你的通话。你告诉自己这是为了一个你希望有一天能为这个历史性时刻制作的项目。
Hi, honey. How are you?
嗨，宝贝。你好吗？
Hello.
你好。
Your aunt and your mom have been living together in Portland since quarantine began.
自隔离开始以来，你阿姨和你妈妈一直住在波特兰。
I'm back.
我回来了。
Your mommy's back. She's here.
你妈妈回来了。她在这儿。
You're back.
你回来了。
We're both here.
我们俩都在这儿。
So does it go from bear to otter, and then to something else? Or it's just bear--
那么它是从熊（bear）变成水獭（otter），然后再变成别的什么吗？还是说这只是熊——
It's not an evolution. It's just different groups.
这不是进化。这只是不同的群体。
OK.
好的。
Twinks are a totally different category, right?
小鲜肉（Twinks）是一个完全不同的类别，对吧？
This is your favorite kind of call. You get stoned and curl up in bed with the phone balanced on your cheek. You are still, at 27, like most children. You like to hear stories of the world before you were in it of your mother before she was your mother, like when her and your aunt were strippers at the New Century Theater in San Francisco.
这是你最喜欢的那种通话。你抽着大麻，蜷缩在床上，电话贴在脸颊上。27岁的你，依然像大多数孩子一样。你喜欢听你在出生前的世界的故事，听你母亲在你出生前作为你母亲的故事，比如当她和你阿姨在旧金山新世纪剧院当脱衣舞女的时候。
And what did you dance to? And what did my mom dance to?
你们跳舞的伴奏是什么？我妈妈跳舞的伴奏是什么？
I would dance to Bob Dylan a lot, actually, believe it or not. But so did your mom.
其实，信不信由你，我经常伴着鲍勃·迪伦跳舞。你妈妈也是。
Well, yeah, but his Christian album. I'm going to scandalize your nephew now. Your auntie did the schoolgirl thing. Let's just be honest. Let's just be honest. Yeah.
嗯，是的，但那是他的基督徒专辑。我现在要让你表弟感到震惊了。你阿姨当时跳的是校服诱惑风。我们老实说吧。我们老实说吧。是的。
Yes.
是的。
Creepy, but I won't think about that.
毛骨悚然，但我不会去想那个。
I know. When you think about it, super creepy.
我知道。当你想到它的时候，超级毛骨悚然。
Well, I'm warning you that my phone is-- you know what? I'm going to go upstairs and get the cord. But I have to look at this message from your brother.
好吧，我警告你我的手机是——你知道吗？我要上楼去拿充电线。但我得看看你兄弟发来的这条信息。
OK, now's your chance, Sayre. Your mom's going upstairs. [LAUGHS] No, go ahead.
好了，现在是你的机会，塞尔。[笑声] 不，去吧。
What, um-- what is her-- what are her-- oh, did you ever meet my birth father?
什么，嗯——她是什么——她们是什么——哦，你见过我的生父吗？
Yeah.
见过。
And what was your general impression?
你对他有什么印象？
He was OK. I only met your birth father a couple of times. I remember I met him once at the Zeitgeist, and he was really hella tall for one thing. He was cute. He was handsome.
他还好。我只见过你生父几次。我记得有一次在 Zeitgeist 酒吧见的，首先他个子非常高。他很可爱。他很帅。
Your mother is not exactly withholding about your father. She answers the questions if you ask them, which you did a lot when you were a teenager. Your origin story has remained consistent but unsatisfyingly brief. Your father was a line cook. He played in a rockabilly band. They met at a bar called the Zeitgeist, dated for a while. She got pregnant. He wasn't ready to be a father. She decided to keep you.
你母亲对于你父亲的事并不是那种遮遮掩掩的人。如果你问她，她会回答，你十几岁时确实经常问。你的起源故事一直保持一致，但极其简短且令人不满足。你父亲是个厨师。他在一支摇滚乐团演奏。他们在一家叫 Zeitgeist 的酒吧相遇，约会了一阵子。她怀孕了。他还没准备好当父亲。她决定把你生下来。
For a while, she exchanged letters with his mother, but your mom says she was always justifying his choice to not be involved in your lives, so they stopped communicating. Your mother tells you his name, but says she can't remember how it's spelled.
有一段时间，她和你父亲的母亲交换过信件，但你妈妈说，她当时总是在为他选择不参与你们的生活做辩护，所以她们停止了联系。你母亲告诉了你他的名字，但说她记不清怎么拼写了。
So yeah. So I met him a couple of times. I thought-- and he seemed nice. He was nice to me. He was polite. He was clearly trying to make a good impression on me because I was your mom's friend. Yeah, and he was very tall.
所以，是的。我见过他几次。我认为——他看起来很不错。他对我很友好。他很礼貌。很明显他试图给我留下好印象，因为我是你妈妈的朋友。是的，而且他非常高。
The pandemic inspires inexplicable life choices. Some friends buzz their hair. Others experiment with sobriety. You move to Los Angeles. You are surprised to find that your next-door neighbors, a young white couple, rarely return your greetings.
疫情激发了一些莫名其妙的人生选择。一些朋友把头发剪成了平头。其他人则尝试禁欲。你搬到了洛杉矶。你惊讶地发现你的隔壁邻居，一对年轻的白人夫妇，很少回应你的问候。
You live in the heart of a gentrifying Central American neighborhood. When you speak to the cashier at the corner store in Spanish, she responds in English. You want to tell her that you're not like the rest of them. Your grandmother's from Santa Ana. You couldn't have afforded to live here a few years ago. You moved here to be closer to something. You're just not sure what or how.
你住在一个正在中产阶级化的中美洲社区中心。当你在街角商店用西班牙语和收银员说话时，她用英语回应。你想告诉她你和他们不一样。你祖母来自圣安娜。几年前你本来根本住不起这里。你搬到这里是为了更接近某样东西。只是你不确定是什么，或者是怎么回事。
Connor is driving his truck up and down the Pacific Coast Highway. He's waiting to be called in to the wildfires, but so far, nobody has called, and he spent the summer sleeping in his truck. On April 18, 2021, a little over a year after he first calls you to ask to look for your father, he texts you a series of screenshots. They're of an exchange between him and someone from a DNA testing website, a distant relative. You bought a kit for your family a few years ago and forgot about it.
康纳开着他的卡车在太平洋海岸公路上来回行驶。他在等候被征召去扑灭野火，但目前为止，没有人给他打电话，整个夏天他都在卡车里睡觉。2021年4月18日，在他第一次打电话给你询问寻找你父亲的事一年多后，他给你发了一系列截图。那是他和一个 DNA 测试网站上的某个人——一个远房亲戚——之间的交流。几年前你给家人买过一个工具包，然后就忘了这回事。
In the exchange, Connor asks if there's someone in this distant relative's family with your birth father's name. Yes, in fact, says the stranger. A few days later, Connor receives your birth father's first and last name, for the first time, spelled correctly. When you search your birth father's name in public records, it returns a result in Los Angeles, in a suburb 40 minutes away from you.
在交流中，康纳询问这个远房亲戚的家族里是否有一个和你生父名字相同的人。事实上是的，陌生人说。几天后，康纳第一次收到了你生父准确拼写的全名。当你在公共记录中搜索你生父的名字时，结果显示他在洛杉矶，在离你40分钟路程的一个郊区。
I mean, how do you feel about it?
我的意思是，你对此有什么感觉？
I feel good about it. Yeah, I feel good about it.
感觉不错。是的，感觉不错。
For me, the first day that we got that info, I was like, I'm kind of excited.
对我来说，得到那个消息的第一天，我就想，我有点兴奋。
It has been a long time since you've heard Connor excited about anything. It's sweet and unnerving. To say no would be disappointing for him, a betrayal of your attempts towards closeness. But the thought of meeting your birth father inspires very little feeling in you, besides a nascent hope that you might finally finish a project.
康纳已经很久没有对任何事情感到兴奋了。这种感觉既甜蜜又令人不安。说“不”会让他失望，背叛了你们走向亲近的尝试。但想到要见到生父，除了内心萌生的一丝希望——你可能终于能完成一个项目之外，并没有给你带来太多的触动。
I mean, do you feel like if you met him, do you feel like you won't get anything out of it?
我的意思是，你觉得如果见到他，你觉得你什么也得不到吗？
I guess I'm just trying to figure out what-- I feel like we're both almost 30, where it's just like, what is this guy going to tell us about ourselves that we don't already know?
我想我只是试图弄清楚什么——我觉得我们都快30岁了，感觉就像是，这个家伙能告诉我们什么关于我们自己，是我们还不知道的？
I hear you because it's like I'm not interested-- it's like I don't really give a shit about-- I mean, I do give a shit. I do give a shit about meeting him. I don't know. Do you ever look in the mirror and, say, think about Dad, or Dad, but our biological dad?
我听到了，因为感觉我也不感兴趣——我的意思是，我并不真的在乎——我的意思是，我在乎。我确实在乎见到他。我不知道。你有没有看着镜子，然后想到爸爸，或者说，爸爸，但我们的亲生父亲？
Yeah. Yeah, definitely.
有。是的，绝对有。
It's like, I find myself always looking and being like, I don't even know what our family looks like. I have Mom to compare that to. I'm like, oh, it's like I have mom's face, in a lot of ways. But I also wonder what our biological dad looks like.
这就像，我发现自己总是看着，心里想，我甚至不知道我们的家人长什么样。我有妈妈可以对比。我想，哦，看起来我有妈妈的脸，在很多方面。但我也想知道我们的亲生父亲长什么样。
You have tabs open to several potential fathers on Facebook, a series of white men in rimless or squared square sunglasses with varied hairlines and gradient palette shades. Your top contender sports a buzz cut and a pair of gas station sunglasses. He's an amateur photographer who takes pictures of animals at the zoo.
你在 Facebook 上打开了几个潜在父亲的标签页，一系列戴着无框或方形太阳镜的白人男子，发际线各异，色调阴影不一。你排名最高的候选人留着寸头，戴着加油站买的那种太阳镜。他是一名业余摄影师，专门拍动物园里的动物。
I found one picture of a person who kind of looks like he could be related to us maybe.
我发现了一张照片，那个人看起来可能和我们有血缘关系，也许。
Yeah, I saw one that maybe did. But I was like, damn, he's pretty ugly. I don't know.
是的，我也看到了一张，也许有。但我当时想，该死，他长得真丑。我不知道。
Is it the guy with the black hair and the sunglasses on?
是那个留着黑发，戴着太阳镜的人吗？
Yeah, that guy. I was like, is that really Mom's type before she started dating really boring dudes?
是的，那个家伙。我当时想，那真的是妈妈在开始和那些很无聊的家伙约会之前的类型吗？
You have not told your mother about any of this, and you're not sure you will. It is very different, you think, to ask questions about your birth father than to meet him.
你还没有告诉母亲任何关于这些的事，而且你不确定你会不会说。你认为询问关于生父的问题和真正见到他是两码事。
And I'm curious about what his life is at.
而且我很好奇他的生活怎么样。
Yeah.
是的。
I also hope he's balling. [LAUGHS] No, I'm just kidding.
我还希望他很有钱。[笑声] 不，我在开玩笑。
Suddenly, it's June again, almost exactly one year since you arrived to Los Angeles. One night, you will absentmindedly google your father's name and Los Angeles. The screen will populate with the same buzzcut guy with gas station sunglasses, but now there are two new images.
突然间，又是六月了，距离你到达洛杉矶几乎正好一年。一天晚上，你心不在焉地搜索了你父亲的名字和洛杉矶。屏幕上弹出了同一个留着寸头、戴着加油站太阳镜的家伙，但现在多了两张新图片。
The first is a man standing beside a barber chair. He looks like he was ripped from a Time magazine article from the '50s-- tall, a pencil mustache, slicked-back hair. There's an interview with him. He owns the barber shop. He grew up in California, moved to Los Angeles in the mid '90s. Before he was a barber, he says, he was a cook.
第一张是一个男人站在理发椅旁。他看起来就像是从50年代的《时代》杂志文章里撕下来的一样——高个子，留着铅笔胡，头发向后梳。有一篇对他的采访。他拥有这家理发店。他在加州长大，90年代中期搬到了洛杉矶。他说，在成为理发师之前，他是一名厨师。
The second image is of him standing in front of the shop. It looks familiar. You will type the address into Google Maps. You ate dinner across the street from the shop two nights ago. You will type in your address to measure the distance between you and this barber shop. A short, nearly straight line will appear and an estimated arrival time from your apartment-- five minutes.
第二张图片是他站在店前。看起来很眼熟。你会把地址输入谷歌地图。两天前你刚在那家店对面吃过晚饭。你会输入你的地址来测量你和这家理发店之间的距离。一条简短、几乎是直线的路径会出现，从你公寓出发的预估到达时间——五分钟。
Coming up, some decisions that need to be made. Stay with us.
接下来，有些决定需要做。留下来，和我们在一起。
It's This American Life. Our story today from Sayre Quevedo continues.
这里是《美国生活》。今天我们的故事来自塞尔·克韦多，继续进行。
[PHONE DIALING]
[电话拨号声]
Hello?
喂？
You've read that there are several theories about the origins of language.
你读到过关于语言起源有几种理论。
Yeah, so I'm going to be in and out. I'm in this weird bunker room right now. I think it's where people who work the crew of Amtrak sleep.
是的，所以我可能待会儿再跟你说。我现在在一个奇怪的掩体房间里。我想这是美国铁路公司乘务员睡觉的地方。
Got you. So should you not be in there talking on the phone?
明白了。那你是不是不应该在那里打电话？
[LAUGHS] No. I don't think it matters.
[笑声] 不。我不觉得这有什么大不了的。
One theory suggests we learn to communicate by imitating nature. Another says we learned through song.
一种理论认为我们通过模仿自然来学会交流。另一种说我们是通过歌唱学习的。
No, I just mean--
不，我只是指——
No.
不。
--to be considerate of other people. Oh, OK. Well, then, that's fine. I wasn't sure if there were, sorry.
——要顾及别人。哦，好的。嗯，那没关系。我不确定是否有人，抱歉。
I'm not talking to you on the phone while people are sleeping.
我不是在有人睡觉的时候跟你打电话。
I'll talk to you soon. I'll talk to you soon. If you're going to be an asshole--
我回头再跟你聊。回头聊。如果你要当个混蛋——
Don't have bad judgment of me. I'm not talking on the phone in front of people who are sleeping. That's a ridiculous thing to think!
别对我产生坏印象。我没在睡觉的人面前打电话。那样想太荒谬了！
I know.
我知道。
These theories of language suggest that either suddenly or over a long period of time, primordial grunts and hums evolved into words, and words allowed us to hunt and pass on knowledge, to gather food and stay safe, to share beliefs and traditions, to express feeling and connect.
这些语言理论表明，要么突然之间，要么经过很长一段时间，原始的咕哝声进化成了词语，词语让我们能够狩猎并传递知识，能够聚集食物并保持安全，能够分享信仰和传统，能够表达情感和建立联系。
Connor, I was just trying to be lighthearted. You don't need to be such a drama queen about it.
康纳，我只是想轻松一点。你没必要表现得那么做作。
I don't think you were. I think you're being judgmental.
我不觉得你是轻松。我觉得你在评头论足。
I was, Connor--
我本来是，康纳——
But--
但是——
Connor--
康纳——
--I'm over it. It's a small thing.
——我不在乎了。这是件小事。
--it's not that deep.
——没那么严重。
That's a small thing.
那是一件小事。
Just chill.
冷静点。
It's a small thing. Drop it. Yes.
那是一件小事。别提了。是的。
It's a small thing. You made it a big thing.
那是一件小事。是你把它变成大事的。
Can we drop it? Can we drop it?
我们能不提了吗？我们能不提了吗？
You can drop it. You drop it.
你可以不提。你别提。
I am dropping it.
我正在不提。
Good, I'm dropping it, too. Do you want to hear about all the work that I did for you, or what? Should we move on?
很好，我也在不提。你想听听我为你做了多少工作吗？还是说我们应该继续往下说？
It's hard to believe that this conversation between you and Connor is the culmination of epochs of human development. And that's because a stubborn critical defect is demonstrated in your and Connor's exchange, that no matter how language evolves, no matter how we choose to use it, there is always a chance that somewhere between thinking, speaking, and hearing, our intention and meaning will be lost.
很难相信你和康纳之间的这次对话是人类文明几个纪元发展的顶点。这是因为在你和康纳的交流中展示了一个顽固的关键缺陷，即无论语言如何进化，无论我们选择如何使用它，总是有可能在思考、说话和倾听之间的某个地方，我们的意图和意义会丢失。
It's not-- it's not a big deal. And--
这不是——这不是什么大不了的事。而且——
OK, let's move on. Let's move on. Let's move on. We both apologized. Let's move on.
好的，我们继续吧。我们继续吧。我们继续吧。我们两个都道歉了。我们继续吧。
OK.
好的。
So basically--
所以基本上——
Jesus.
天哪。
On your computer screen are seven discrete tabs tucked next to your work email. They've been open since last night. The first tab, the article about your birth father's barbershop that you found yesterday.
你的电脑屏幕上有七个独立的标签页，紧挨着你的工作邮箱。它们从昨晚起就一直开着。第一个标签页，关于你生父理发店的文章，那是你昨天找到的。
You said the shop is nearby. Do you know what kind of shop he has?
你说店在附近。你知道他开的是什么店吗？
It's a barber shop.
是一家理发店。
Oh, he's a barber.
哦，他是个理发师。
The second, third, and fourth tabs are a mosaic of images from Google, Facebook, and Yelp. There's your birth father standing behind the barber chair or behind the wheel of a classic Cadillac. There he is in a tiki bar or squinting into the sun, his pencil mustache, his eyebrows, and the slits of his eyes creating five distinct planes across his face. His pompadour catches an errant sunray.
第二个、第三个和第四个标签页是来自谷歌、Facebook 和 Yelp 的图片拼贴。那是你的生父，站在理发椅后或一辆经典凯迪拉克的方向盘后。他在一家提基酒吧里，或者眯着眼睛看着太阳，他的铅笔胡、眉毛以及他眼睛的缝隙在他脸上构成了五个截然不同的平面。他的大背头捕捉到了一缕迷离的阳光。
Yeah, I mean, he's like a rockabilly dude, which is a big red flag to me, just in general.
是的，我的意思是，他是个摇滚乐男孩，这对我来说是一个大红旗，通常来说。
The fifth tab is the map with directions to his barber shop. A short, nearly straight line measures the distance between you-- five minutes.
第五个标签页是带有理发店方向的地图。一条简短、几乎是直线的路径测量了你之间的距离——五分钟。
He's right there next to you. That's so wild actually. That's-- it's kind of baffling.
他就离你那么近。那真的很野。那——有点令人困惑。
The sixth tab is the barber shop's Yelp reviews, in which your father is rated from a scale of 0 to 5 stars, with additional notes included. He averages about 4.1. According to the anecdotal evidence in these reviews, he is either the nicest or the worst man they've ever met. He is unforgiving of lateness, condescending, rude, a, quote, "complete asshole," or fastidious, a perfectionist, the best men's barber in town.
第六个标签页是理发店的 Yelp 评论，其中你父亲的评分从0到5颗星不等，并附有额外的备注。他的平均分大约是4.1。根据这些评论中的轶事证据，他要么是他们见过的最好的人，要么是最差的人。他不能容忍迟到、傲慢、粗鲁，引用评论是“彻头彻尾的混蛋”，或者是挑剔、完美主义者，城里最好的男士理发师。
Here's a really good picture of his face that I can see up close.
这儿有一张他脸部很清晰的照片，我可以近距离看清楚。
Mm-hmm. The one where he's standing behind the barber chair.
嗯。就是那张他站在理发椅后的照片。
Wow. Wow. That's our-- that's our daddy right there. I see-- I see you in him. Thanks for doing all the hard work finding all that.
哇。哇。那就是我们的——那就是我们的爸爸。我看到——我在你身上看到了他。谢谢你做完所有这些找到这些资料的辛苦工作。
No, thank you. I love you.
不，谢谢你。我爱你。
You're welcome, I guess. I don't know what you're thanking me for.
不客气，我想。我不知道你在谢我什么。
Well, you're the one who found the name, so-- I mean, it's not all-- not all my work.
嗯，是你找到了名字，所以——我的意思是，这不是全部——不是我一个人的工作。
I know it's not, but thank you.
我知道不是，但谢谢你。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
All right.
好的。
Yeah, I love you.
是的，我爱你。
All right. I love you too, brother. Keep me in the loop.
好的。我也爱你，兄弟。随时跟我保持联系。
Yeah, I'll text you tonight. Bye.
好的，我今晚发信息给你。再见。
OK, all right. Love you, bye.
好的，好的。爱你，再见。
Talk to you later. Bye.
回头聊。再见。
It's summer in Los Angeles, 2021. You are 28 years old, and you have a routine. You wake up, you answer an endless stream of work emails and Slack messages, which fill you with an unearned rage and dread. You smoke weed which relaxes you or puts you on edge with no in-between. You cook chicken and coconut rice and eat it standing at the wall-mounted table in your narrow kitchen.
2021年夏天，洛杉矶。你28岁，你有你的日常作息。你醒来，回复一连串无休止的工作邮件和 Slack 信息，这些让你感到一种无名的愤怒和恐惧。你抽大麻，这让你放松，或者让你紧张，没有任何中间状态。你做鸡肉椰子饭，站在狭窄厨房的壁挂桌旁吃完。
Sometimes your friend Sarah picks you up, and you drive around LA, attempting to commit to memory the geography around you. You forget it by the time you've walked through the front door.
有时你的朋友莎拉会接你，你们开车在洛杉矶转悠，试图记下周围的地理位置。当你走进前门时，你就已经忘了。
You smoke a cigarette in the parking lot behind your apartment. You scroll on Instagram. You swipe on dating apps.
你在公寓后的停车场抽根烟。你刷着 Instagram。你在交友软件上滑动。
I'm going to record myself on Tinder because that is what I have been doing lately.
我要在 Tinder 上记录我自己，因为这就是我最近一直在做的。
You can't say exactly what you're looking for. It's easier to say what you are not.
你无法确切说出你在寻找什么。说出你不想要什么更容易。
Bio says, hiking, comma, gym, 5'9, 1,000 miles away. No. No. Meh, little vanilla. No. No. No.
个人资料上写着，徒步，逗号，健身房，5英尺9英寸，1000英里外。不。不。一般，有点平庸。不。不。不。
You don't want to date an artist-- too earnest. You don't want to date a banker or a real estate agent. And frankly, bankers and real estate agents don't really want to date you either. Your teeth are slightly crooked. You have never in your adult life seen your abs without yanking the pouch down on your stomach. Also, you're bad with money.
你不想和一个艺术家约会——太一本正经了。你不想和一个银行家或房地产经纪人约会。坦率地说，银行家和房地产经纪人也并不真的想和你约会。你的牙齿有点歪。你成年后从来没有在没用力吸肚子的情况下看到过自己的腹肌。而且，你对金钱管理很糟糕。
His job is entrepreneur, which, what the fuck is an entrepreneur? I'm going to say no.
他的职业是企业家，他妈的企业家是什么鬼？我要选不。
No athletes. You smoke and drink and do drugs that keep you from waking up before sunrise.
不要运动员。你抽烟、喝酒，还会吸食让你在日出前无法醒来的毒品。
Patrick-- let's go on a hike and then eat what we just burned off. No. This person was like, I love having fun. Like, what? Who doesn't like having fun.
帕特里克——我们去徒步，然后吃掉我们刚刚消耗掉的能量。不。这个人就像，我喜欢玩得开心。像是，什么？谁不喜欢玩得开心。
You don't want to date anyone who makes regular pilgrimage to Disneyland or feels affiliation with any of their characters or Harry Potter. This turns out to be particularly damning criteria in Los Angeles.
你不想和任何会定期去迪士尼乐园朝圣的人约会，也不想和任何觉得与他们的角色或哈利·波特有关联的人约会。事实证明，这在洛杉矶是一个特别该死的标准。
Ah, he plays golf with his friends. Yeah, this is not going to work. Just a picture with no bad vibes today. Text, over it. No thank you. No, he's a singer. No, thank you. He looks like he's got big arms that he could wrap around you, but I'm going to say no.
啊，他和朋友打高尔夫球。是的，这行不通。就一张没有坏氛围的照片今天。文字，无感。不用了谢谢。不，他是个歌手。不用了谢谢。他看起来有粗壮的胳膊，可以环抱住你，但我还是要选不。
OK, guys being dudes is the name of this one. Come get sandwiched between two men. No, thank you. I mean, yes, but not with them.
好的，男人就是男人是这个的标题。快来被两个男人夹在中间。不用了谢谢。我的意思是，是，但不是和他们。
You don't want to date someone who only has white friends, but you're also afraid to date someone who is so connected to their cultural background that you feel like a white person in comparison with your unplaceable face, afro, and Gaelic name.
你不想和一个只有白人朋友的人约会，但你也害怕和一个与其文化背景联系太紧密的人约会，这让你在拥有无法确定的面容、爆炸头和盖尔语名字的你面前感觉像个白人。
Far leftist progressive. Oh, shit, OK, and hella cute. Oh, fuck. This is the funniest part, too, is that you get all in your head about saying yes, saying no, and then they never swipe for you. So it's sort of a useless exercise.
极左进步主义者。噢，该死，好吧，而且超级可爱。噢，去你的。这是最有趣的部分，就是你会在脑子里纠结说“是”还是说“不”，然后他们从来不会滑你。所以这算是一种无用的练习。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hi, baby.
嗨，宝贝。
Hi, Mama.
嗨，妈妈。
How are you?
你好吗？
Good. How are you doing?
很好。你怎么样？
I'm doing good. I saw your brother yesterday. It was super sweet.
我很好。我昨天见到你兄弟了。超级可爱。
Oh, yeah?
哦，是吗？
Hello? Yeah.
喂？是的。
Yeah.
是的。
So how are you feeling about what he wants to do?
那么你对他想要做的事有什么感觉？
The truth is you don't feel anything about meeting your father. You know that in theory this is big. You're about to meet someone who once meant something to you and now means something else. But you won't be sure what until he's in front of you.
事实上，对于见到你父亲，你没有任何感觉。你知道在理论上这是一件大事。你即将见到一个曾经对你意味着什么，现在又意味着别的东西的人。但在见到他之前，你无法确定是什么。
I don't know. It's cool. I don't know. I don't know how I'm-- like, I mean, how do I feel about it? It's hard to say, you know?
我不知道。很酷。我不知道。我不知道我是怎么——我的意思是，我对此有什么感觉？很难说，你知道吗？
Well, I love you guys, and I hope that you get what you need from it. And yeah, I'm glad you're doing it together.
嗯，我爱你们俩，我希望你们能从中得到你们需要的。而且是的，我很高兴你们一起做这件事。
You find an email address on the barber shop's website. You click into the always-open email tab on your computer and start a new message. Your first words to your birth father will forever be archived in your inbox between updates to your credit score, calendar reminders of work deadlines, and your lease renewal.
你在理发店的网站上找到了一个电子邮箱。你点击电脑上一直开着的邮件标签页，开始写一封新邮件。你对生父说的第一句话将永远归档在你的收件箱里，夹在你的信用评分更新、工作截止日期的日历提醒和租赁续约合同之间。
The cursor ticks an even measure on the blank draft. This blank space must be filled with something specific. A particular alchemy must take place, a certain tone struck. Whatever fills this space must be firm but not aggressive, humble but not shrinking.
光标在空白的草稿上均匀地跳动。这个空白处必须填入具体的东西。某种化学反应必须发生，某种语调必须确立。填补这个空间的任何东西都必须坚定但不激进，谦逊但不卑微。
Do you have any idea how to start?
你知道怎么开始吗？
How about, Hello. I know this is a bit out of the blue, but I'm sending this message on behalf of my brother and I. We think you are our biological father.
怎么样，你好。我知道这有点突然，但我代表我和我兄弟发这条信息。我们认为你是我们的亲生父亲。
Start with that preface thing you're talking about. We're not looking to get anything from you.
从你说的那个前言开始。我们不是要从你那得到什么。
How about this? I know this is a bit out of the blue, but I'm sending this message on behalf of my brother and I. We think you are our biological father. We're not--
这个怎么样？我知道这有点突然，但我代表我和我兄弟发这条信息。我们认为你是我们的亲生父亲。我们不是——
That sounds so formal and weird.
听起来太正式、太奇怪了。
We don't need anything from you. We don't-- we're not asking for anything.
我们不需要你什么。我们不——我们没要求什么。
I might want to ask him for something.
我可能想问他要点什么。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I'll be like, hey, can you pay for my schooling?
我会说，嘿，你能付我的学费吗？
Connor, please don't ruin this before we've even had the chance to meet him. Please.
康纳，拜托不要在我们有机会见到他之前就把它搞砸了。拜托。
I won't. I won't. Yeah, it still sounds formal. It still sounds like what are you-- We'd love to talk, blah, blah, blah. But it could be like, we think that you might be our biological father. Whatever. We're really hoping that we could meet you and fill in the blank, something personal.
不会的。不会的。是的，还是听起来很正式。还是听起来像你是什么——我们很想谈谈，巴拉巴拉。但它可以是，我们认为你可能是我们的亲生父亲。不管怎样。我们真的很希望我们能见到你，填补空白，一些私人的东西。
We're both nearly 30--
我们都快30岁了——
Yeah.
是的。
--and have always wondered about who you were.
——而且一直好奇你是谁。
Yeah, that sounds good to me. Does that sound good to you?
是的，这对我也很受用。这对你来说听起来不错吗？
Yeah, I'm sending it.
是的，我正在发送。
All right.
好的。
Ready? 3--
准备好了吗？3——
Yeah. Smash that motherfucking button. Sorry. Yeah. I'm ready. You can count down if you want.
是的。按下那个该死的按钮。抱歉。是的。我准备好了。你想倒数的话就倒数吧。
What should I put as the subject line?
主题行我该写什么？
Say, like, Happy Father's day.
写，比如，父亲节快乐。
Papa, can you hear me? No. Are you my daddy?
爸爸，你能听见我吗？不。你是我的爸爸吗？
How about long lost kids in search of biological father.
长失散的孩子寻找亲生父亲怎么样。
That's a long subject, not just--
这是一个很长的主题，不仅仅是——
Dad, question mark?
爸爸，问号？
I'm just going to put a hello from Connor and Sayre. How about that?
我只是要写一个来自康纳和塞尔的问候。那个怎么样？
Reaching out.
接触。
All right, 1, 2, 3. All right, I did it.
好的，1, 2, 3。好的，我做了。
Nice. Now we wait.
很好。现在我们等。
Our story continues after a break from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues. It's This American Life. We are in the middle of excerpts from Sayre Quevedo's new series Reaching Out. Let's pick up where we left off.
我们的故事在芝加哥公共广播电台休息后继续，当我们的节目继续时。这里是《美国生活》。我们正在节目中摘录塞尔·克韦多的新系列《接触》。让我们从刚才结束的地方接着讲。
You wait four days to hear back, but nothing. There's no way to know the message was received, that it didn't end up in his spam folder or that a coworker didn't delete it assuming it was a phishing scam. But the notion of these possibilities is enough to convince you that it's worth reaching out once more. So you call the shop.
你等了四天期待回音，但什么都没有。没法知道信息是否被收到，没有落入他的垃圾邮件文件夹，或者没有被同事误删以为是钓鱼诈骗。但这些可能性的想法足以让你确信，值得再联系一次。所以你给店里打了电话。
Hello?
喂？
Hello.
喂。
Hi.
嗨。
He's in the bathroom, says the voice on the other end of the line.
他在洗手间，电话那头的声音说道。
So it's Sayre-- S-A-Y-R-E?
所以是塞尔——S-A-Y-R-E？
Yeah, and Connor-- C-O-N-N-O-R.
是的，还有康纳——C-O-N-N-O-R。
You leave your names and number.
你留下了你们的名字和号码。
Sure. It's 510--
好的。是510——
What do you think? Do you think he was actually in the bathroom?
你觉得呢？你认为他真的在洗手间吗？
I don't know. Dude, it sounds-- it's like one of those things that could be true, but it also could be a really lame excuse, and it's hard to know.
我不知道。伙计，听起来——这就像那种可能是真的，但也可以是一个非常烂的借口的事情，很难说。
Yeah. Well, if he calls you tonight, I guess let me know.
是的。好吧，如果他今晚给你回电话，我想让我知道。
Yeah, I will.
是的，我会的。
You don't hear back, and you don't call back either. You and Connor don't even discuss it. It seems to go without saying that to reach out a third time with no response would be pathetic.
你没收到回音，也没再打回去。你和康纳甚至没有讨论过这件事。无需多言似乎就是，第三次联系却没有回应将是可悲的。
Sometimes in the weeks after, you find yourself driving past your father's shop. You peer through the window, hoping to catch his face. It's not that it particularly matters to you. You've just become habituated to looking for him.
在接下来的几周里，有时你会发现自己开车经过你父亲的店。你透过窗户盯着看，希望能捕捉到他的脸。并不是因为这特别对你重要。你只是习惯了寻找他。
You've gone out alone again tonight. In the months since quarantine was lifted, this has become your weekend routine. You stay out at your neighborhood bar until close with your back to the wall and your eyes on the door. You're waiting for someone to walk in who will change the course of your evening.
今晚你又独自出去了。自隔离解除以来的几个月里，这成了你的周末日常。你待在社区酒吧直到打烊，背靠着墙，眼睛盯着门。你在等某个人走进来，能改变你今晚进程的人。
Hours pass like this, lost continents floating at the bottom of your pint glass. At an interval of every hour, you ask the universe for a sign that it's time to go home. But if it's sent, you are too busy watching the door to notice.
时光就这样流逝，迷失的大陆漂浮在你的品脱杯底。每过一小时，你就向宇宙请求一个该回家了的信号。但如果它发出了，你正忙着盯着门看而没有注意到。
All right. I am walking home. I'm drunk.
好了。我正在走路回家。我喝醉了。
Last call is over. Now you're stumbling home, feeling bad for yourself, of course.
最后一次点单结束了。现在你踉踉跄跄地回家，当然，觉得很对不起自己。
Thought that-- stupidly thought that if I went to the nearby gay bar next to my house that I might meet someone, but no.
以为——愚蠢地以为如果我去了我家附近的同性恋酒吧，也许能遇到某个人，但没有。
You're on Santa Monica Boulevard now. The leather bar you visit on other nights, sometimes the same night, is to your left. You won't go in tonight. You're already too drunk. The circuit is your Bermuda Triangle, and somewhere along the vertices, you black out. The only evidence of whoever is navigating your body is in these recordings.
你现在在圣莫尼卡大道上。你有时在其他晚上光顾的皮衣酒吧，有时是同一个晚上，就在你的左边。今晚你不会进去。你已经喝得太醉了。这个回路是你的百慕大三角，在顶点的某个地方，你断片了。谁在操纵你的身体的唯一证据就在这些录音里。
Nothing is nothing. It's all bullshit, all of it.
什么都不是什么。全都是狗屁，全都是。
To attempt to intuit what bullshit you are referring to from this side of the veil is impossible. Could be anything-- the bullshit of this age, this time, the bullshit of leaving your home only to find that the world is exactly as you left it but with more rules, more distance, more death and indifference. The bullshit of risking disease, waiting for someone to notice you at a bar. The bullshit of knowing that's a waste of time. The bullshit of wanting it anyway. The bullshit of steeling yourself against disappointment by expecting nothing, only to find yourself still disappointed when nothing is exactly what you receive. And then this, whatever this is.
试图从面纱的这一侧去直觉你所指的“狗屁”是什么是不可能的。可能是任何东西——这个时代的狗屁，这个时刻的狗屁，离开家却发现世界一如既往但有着更多规则、更多距离、更多死亡和冷漠的狗屁。冒着疾病风险，在酒吧等着别人注意到你的狗屁。明知那是浪费时间却还是去做这些的狗屁。无论如何都想要它的狗屁。通过期待什么都不发生来防御失望，却发现当真的什么都没发生时你依然感到失望的狗屁。然后这个，不管这是什么。
I think I'm going to pee.
我想我要尿尿。
Tomorrow's headache creeping in as you piss behind a tree-- same bullshit, your bullshit, followed by a bean burrito at 7-eleven.
当你在一棵树后撒尿时，明天的头痛感悄然而至——同样的狗屁，你的狗屁，接着是7-11便利店的豆子卷饼。
Same bullshit every day. Same shit every day. Nothing matters.
每天都是同样的狗屁。每天都是同样的狗屁。什么都不重要。
Connor and you know there is only one option left. You have to go and meet your father in person. But you haven't talked much since calling your father's shop, and choosing a date is an overture in your conversation with no resolution.
你和康纳知道只剩下最后一个选择。你们必须去亲身见你们的父亲。但自从给你们父亲的店打电话后你们聊得不多，确定一个日期在你们的对话中是一次毫无结果的尝试。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
How's it going?
怎么样了？
What are you doing?
你在干什么？
Good. I just woke up a bit ago. I'm going to take a shower.
很好。我刚醒没多久。我要去冲个澡。
Oh, nice. You just woke up?
哦，真好。你刚醒？
A little bit ago.
刚才一点。
It's 1:30.
都1点半了。
I know.
我知道。
That's crazy.
太疯狂了。
You never sent me dates.
你从来没发给我日期。
I know because a bunch of things happened, which is why I was calling you about. Anyway, fuck, dude. I'm really distracted. I'm sorry.
我知道，因为发生了一堆事，所以我才给你打电话的。总之，去你的，伙计。我很分心。我很抱歉。
I know. Why did you call me while you were doing something else? Do you want to just--
我知道。为什么你在做别的事的时候给我打电话？你想只是——
You can tell?
你能看出来？
Just tell me. Yeah, but just-- just-- finish one thing and then do the other. Finish one thing and then do the other. Don't do both at the same time.
直接告诉我就行。是的，但只是——只是——做完一件事再做另一件。做完一件事再做另一件。不要同时做两件事。
OK.
好的。
Just choose one thing and then do the other.
选一件事做，然后再做另一件。
You're grumpy.
你脾气暴躁。
I am grumpy.
我是脾气暴躁。
It's not my fault.
这不是我的错。
It's not your fault, but don't call people while you're doing other things.
不是你的错，但不要在做别的事的时候打电话。
If you want to talk at a better time when you're less hungover.
如果你想在一个更好的时候聊，等你酒醒一点。
No, I want to talk. I've been trying to get a date. I've been trying to get a date from you for, like, the last two weeks, so just tell me.
不，我想谈。我一直在试图定个日期。在过去两周里，我一直在试图从你那定个日期，所以直接告诉我。
I know. Well, Sayre, it's really fucking hard with what I do for work. I don't think you really understand that, and I don't blame you for it. It's just like there's an understanding of seasonal work that I don't think you get. But it's really like-- you just kind of put your life on the line and really hope that you get work. I don't have as much freedom as you in some sense. Like, I probably can't make it down at least until December, which I'm totally OK with doing if you want to. But I also understand.
我知道。嗯，塞尔，考虑到我的工作，这真的很他妈困难。我不觉得你真的理解，我不怪你。这只是——对季节性工作有一种理解，我不觉得你明白。但这真的像是——你把生命押在赌注上，真的希望你能找到工作。在某种意义上，我没有你那么自由。比如，我大概至少要到十二月才能去，如果你想的话，我完全可以。但我也理解。
I'm going to be-- I'm going to be out of town in December, so I can't do it then.
十二月我要出城，所以那天不行。
OK, well, do you want to do January?
好的，那你想要一月吗？
I mean, do you want to do it? I guess, like, that's the thing I want to figure out.
我的意思是，你想做吗？我想，这就是我想要弄清楚的事情。
Do I want to?
我想做吗？
Yeah, I mean, do you want to do it? I guess do we have to see him? I don't know. What are we going to do, like, go up to him and-- like, what are we going to get out of that, you know?
是的，我的意思是，你想做吗？我想我们非得见他不可吗？我不知道。我们要去干什么，像是，去找他，然后——我们能从那得到什么，你知道吗？
I don't know. I mean, I just want to talk to him. I want to meet him. I want to know. I want to know his health problems. I want to know his family's shit. You know, I don't know, just basic things like that, see what he's like, if he's a dick, if he's cool, if he likes to party. I don't know. You don't know. Definitely a story. What do you want out of it?
我不知道。我的意思是，我只是想和他谈谈。我想见他。我想知道。我想知道他的健康问题。我想知道他家里那些破事。你知道，我不知道，只是基本的事情，看看他是什么样，他是不是个混蛋，他酷不酷，他爱不爱玩。我不知道。你不知道。绝对是个故事。你从中想得到什么？
Connor wants to meet your father on the most physical plane-- cash, genetics, ancestry. You're not sure what you want. It's hard to say without knowing what you can ask for.
康纳想在最物理的层面上见到你父亲——金钱、基因、血缘。你不确定你想要什么。很难说，不知道你能要求什么。
I don't know if I want anything out of it.
我不知道我想从中得到什么。
Yeah, I think that's OK, too. But, you know, I guess if you don't want to do it, I'm not going to do it either. I'll only do it if you want to do it.
是的，我觉得那也可以。但是，你知道，我想如果你不想做，我也不做了。只有你想要做，我才做。
No, I'm-- no, I'll do it. I want to do it because you want to do it.
不，我是——不，我会做。我想做是因为你想要做。
So I guess we'll both do it.
所以我想我们俩都会做。
One day, you find yourself standing across the street from your birth father's shop. You don't intend to show up. It's as if you've come out of a trance. You look up and you're there. The fall's high sun beats down on your shoulders as you stare through the window.
一天，你发现自己站在你生父理发店的对面。你并不打算出现。就好像你从恍惚中走出来。你抬头看，你就站在那儿。秋天高耸的太阳照射在你的肩膀上，你盯着窗户看。
Did you see him?
你看到他了吗？
I smoked a cigarette and watched him work.
我抽了一根烟，看着他工作。
What was that like for you?
那对你来说是什么感觉？
You watch what you believe is your father's silhouette, his hands working over the client's head. Four months since you emailed, four months since you called, and all you have to show for it is this impotent act.
你看着你认为是父亲的剪影，他的手在客人的头上工作。距离你发邮件已经过去四个月，距离你打电话已经过去四个月，你所展示的只有这种无能为力的行为。
And I felt sort of like you can't do [BLEEP] to me, you know? And, like, you're not-- you can't affect me. You can't stop me from being here, you know? And I guess maybe a little hurt, too, like the feeling of oh, wow, you're just, like, living-- continuing to live your life like you always have. Like I did think about the fact that we sent him an email, and gave him a call, and left our number, and that he's, like-- still gets to live his life like he's-- like nothing is different, you know?
我感觉就像[消音]对我做不了什么，你知道吗？而且，你不是——你不能影响我。你不能阻止我在这里，你知道吗？我想也许也有一点受伤，就像那种感觉，噢，哇，你只是，就像，活着——继续过你的生活，就像你一直以来那样。因为我确实想过这样一个事实，我们发了邮件，打了电话，留下了我们的号码，而他，就像——依然能过着他的生活，就像他——什么都没改变，你知道吗？
The reason language so often fails us, despite eons of development. It's not that we fail to choose the right words or that others stopped short of hearing and then comprehending us, but that another, more honest meaning is forged between and apart from what we say in silence.
语言之所以经常让我们失望，尽管有了万年的发展。并不是我们没能选择正确的词语，或者别人没能听懂并理解我们，而是在沉默中，在我们的言语之间和之外，锻造出了另一种更诚实的意义。
Silence, unlike language, cannot be improved upon. It has its own clarifying syntax. It reveals what we are too afraid to put into words. It is in these ellipses that our full intention and meaning are revealed. And perhaps it is our unwillingness to accept what silence declares where our suffering truly begins.
沉默，与语言不同，是无法被改善的。它有自己清晰的语法。它揭示了我们太害怕用语言表达的东西。正是这些省略号揭示了我们全部的意图和意义。也许我们痛苦的真正开始，就在于我们不愿意接受沉默所宣告的事实。
So you want to confront him. What is it that you want to-- what do you want to achieve with the confrontation?
所以你想面对他。你想要什么——你面对他想要达到什么目的？
I just want him to know that we exist and that, yeah-- and that it hurts that he didn't acknowledge us, but also that we'll be fine without him.
我只是想让他知道我们存在，而且，是的——他没有承认我们确实很受伤，但也想让他知道没有他我们也会过得很好。
By saying those things, you feel like what? Like what will happen?
通过说这些，你觉得是什么感觉？像是，会发生什么？
I don't know. I guess in a weird way I feel like I will be able to get over my issues. I feel like yeah-- I feel it's like I can finally move past that one thing, you know?
我不知道。我猜以一种奇怪的方式，我觉得我将能克服我的问题。我觉得是的——我觉得就像我终于能越过那件事了，你知道吗？
So do you think that's actually true? I mean, that makes perfect sense to me, sweetie, you know, that you would think that that would happen. You confront the thing that haunts you. You tell it. You end it. But the question is, does it really end it? That's the question. Does it really end it?
所以你认为那是真的吗？我的意思是，那对我来说完全说得通，亲爱的，你知道，你会认为那会发生。你面对缠绕你的事物。你告诉它。你终结它。但问题是，它真的终结了吗？那是问题所在。它真的终结了吗？
You write your message on a blank sheet of printer paper torn in half. Of all of your attempted correspondences, this one is the most to the point-- name and intention. Why bother with anything else?
你在一张撕成两半的空白打印纸上写下你的信息。在你所有尝试的通信中，这封是最切中要害的——姓名和意图。为什么要折腾别的？
Hi, you write. We're your sons. We've tried reaching out to you. We'd like to meet you. We've booked your 5 o'clock appointment. We'll be waiting across the street in front of the café and would love to speak. Connor and Sayre.
嗨，你写道。我们是你的儿子。我们尝试过联系你。我们想见你。我们预约了你5点钟的档期。我们会在马路对面咖啡馆前等着，很想谈谈。康纳和塞尔。
I'm going to write his name on the front.
我要在前面写上他的名字。
Yeah. I mean, the thing is, too, is what if he's right there?
是的。我的意思是，问题也是，如果他就在那儿呢？
I mean, we're going to hand it to him. Yeah, So he is going to be right there.
我的意思是，我们会亲手交给他。是的，所以他会就在那儿。
How are you going to do that?
你要怎么做？
You have booked your birth father's last appointment of the day at his barber shop. When he calls you up for your haircut, you'll hand him the note, telling him to meet you across the street.
你预约了你生父当天最后的时间。当他叫你进去理发时，你会把字条交给他，让他到马路对面找你。
How are you going to do that?
你要怎么做？
Walk up to him and go, like, hi, we're you're 5 o'clock. I'm your 5 o'clock. One of us will have to do it. I'm your 5 o'clock. Hand it to him, and then we'll walk out.
走上前去说，嘿，我们是你5点钟的预约。我是你的5点钟。我们其中一个必须得去说。我是你的5点钟。递给他，然后我们走出来。
Do you want to do that?
你想那样做吗？
I can do it. Do you want to do it?
我可以做。你想做吗？
No.
不。
OK.
好的。
Not at all.
一点也不。
It's spring of 2022 in Los Angeles. You are 29 years old. It's been nearly a year since you first sent your email to your birth father asking to meet, nearly two years to the day since Connor first called you and asked to look for your birth father. Now your brother is here in front of you, hunched in front of the mirror, pulling his hair into two loose braids.
2022年春天，洛杉矶。你29岁。距离你第一次给生父发邮件要求见面已经过去将近一年，距离康纳第一次打电话给你要求寻找生父已经过去将近两年。现在你的兄弟就在你面前，蜷缩在镜子前，把头发扎成两根松散的辫子。
It's 4:23 PM.
下午4:23。
We should probably get going.
我们可能该出发了。
Yeah, we should get going because we're going to need time to park and stuff, too. Are you ready, Connor?
是的，我们该出发了，因为我们需要时间停车之类的。你准备好了吗，康纳？
Yeah. Let me just make sure I have everything.
是的。让我确认我带了所有东西。
You're both quiet as you walk out the door.
你们俩走出门口时都很安静。
OK. OK.
好的。好的。
How are you feeling?
感觉怎么样？
I'm scared. I'm nervous.
我很害怕。我很紧张。
Yeah. What are you nervous about?
是的。你因为什么紧张？
That he's going to be mean.
他会很刻薄。
Yeah. Well, he doesn't really have the right to be mean.
是的。好吧，他其实没权利刻薄。
Yeah, but that doesn't stop anyone from being mean.
是的，但这并不能阻止任何人刻薄。
No, but I don't know. I mean, I have-- I mean, I feel defensive of you. So if he was mean to us, I'd think about it as he's mean to you, where I'd care more, I guess.
不，但我不知道。我的意思是，我有——我的意思是，我觉得为你感到防御。所以如果他对我们刻薄，我会认为这是他对你刻薄，那样我会更在乎，我想。
That's mostly what-- I'm afraid of him being mean to you, too. I don't really care what he says to me. I don't want him to hurt you.
我大多是这样——我怕他对你也刻薄。我不在乎他对我说什么。我不希望他伤害你。
Same here.
我也是。
You pull down the driveway and onto the mile that separates you from your birth father. This street is ordinary to you now. In the nearly two years you have lived here, you have driven it hundreds of times, walked it drunk, sweaty, in the rain. You've kissed strangers on the street at midnight, mouth full of ash.
你开车下车道，来到那条隔开你和生父的一英里路上。这条街对你来说现在很平常。在你住在这里的近两年里，你开车经过了数百次，醉醺醺地走过，汗流浃背，雨中。你在午夜街头亲吻过陌生人，满嘴烟灰。
Time widens the aperture. Certain features pass flat against the windshield as you drive. Others stay inexplicably in the fore-- the laundromat that you went to the day you arrived here, the bar with the barnhouse facade, which you will never step inside of the entire time you live in Los Angeles, the white house with busts lined across the roof and a headless angel in the yard, the psychic's front porch.
时间拓宽了光圈。某些特征在你开车经过时显得平淡。其他特征却莫名其妙地留在前方——你搬到这里那天去过的自助洗衣店，有谷仓外立面的酒吧，你在住在洛杉矶期间从未踏入过一次，屋顶排列着半身像、院子里有一个无头天使的白房子，算命先生的前廊。
What time is it?
几点了？
It's 4:34. 4:34.
4:34。4:34。
OK.
好的。
Ah. OK, well, we're outside of it. Hmm. This somehow got so much harder now that we're here.
啊。好吧，我们就在外面。嗯。既然到了这里，事情变得更加困难了。
You are now 20 minutes early, which gives Connor time to reconsider the plan entirely.
你现在提前了20分钟，这给了康纳足够的时间重新考虑整个计划。
Do you think we should try-- I know you plan on doing the note, but do you think that we should call him?
你认为我们应该试着——我知道你打算用字条，但你认为我们应该给他打电话吗？
Yeah, but we already tried calling.
是的，但我们已经试过打电话了。
But we call his barbershop and be like, hey, I've got an appointment for him at 5 o'clock. He'll say, yeah, sure, let me check.
但我们可以给理发店打电话，说，嘿，我给他预约了5点钟。他会说，好的，当然，让我检查一下。
And then what, say exactly what's in the note? Say we're outside?
然后呢，说和字条上一样的话？说我们在外面？
Hey, yeah, this is your sons.
嘿，是的，这是你的儿子。
What if he hangs up?
如果他挂断了怎么办？
Then we go in there.
那我们就进去。
And do what?
然后做什么？
We say, fuck you.
我们说，去你的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I don't know. I'm OK with doing that. I've always wanted to say fuck you to dad. Do you want to go in together? Would that make you feel better about it?
我不知道。我愿意那样做。我一直想对爸爸说“去你的”。你想一起进去吗？那会让你感觉好受点吗？
I mean, if you want to, I'm down.
我的意思是，如果你想的话，我奉陪。
I want him to look at us in the case that he decides that he doesn't want to deal with it, so that he can at least do it once if he decides to avoid conversation with us, at least going in there and him seeing our face. I can be like, hey, I'm here, and I see you.
我希望他看着我们，以防他决定不想应付这件事，这样至少如果他决定避免和我们对话，至少进去一次让他看到我们的脸。我可以像，嘿，我在这儿，我看着你。
OK, two minutes. One minute till 5:00. OK. Are you ready?
好的，两分钟。离5点还有一分钟。好的。你准备好了吗？
Yeah, you?
是的，你呢？
As ready as I can be.
正如我所能准备好的那样。
[CHATTER]
[嘈杂声]
The first words your birth father ever says to you-- do you have an appointment?
你生父对你说的第一句话——你有预约吗？
Yeah, 5:00.
是的，5点。
You sit down and wait your turn. You can barely get yourself to look up at him. You fix your eyes first on the wine-colored tiles, then the client's sneakers slack against the footrest, the shapeless, oversized black barber's tarp, then your father's hands as he trims stray hairs, chatting easily over the jazz music playing softly over the speakers.
你坐下来等候。你几乎无法让自己抬头看他。你先把眼睛固定在酒红色的瓷砖上，然后是客人的运动鞋在脚垫上松弛着，那件不成形的、超大的黑色理发披风，然后是你父亲的手，当他修剪杂毛时，在音箱里轻柔播放的爵士乐声中轻松聊天。
The walls are lined with framed photographs of what you assume were once famous Hollywood actors whose faces you do not recognize and names you do not know. In the corner, a magazine rack full of vintage Playboy magazines. Your birth father brushes clean his client's forehead and nape with a blond duster brush, says goodbye cheerily. He glances over at you and Connor and then calmly walks to the back door of the shop. He disappears for five seconds, then 10, then 15. He returns with a broom and slowly, methodically sweeps the hair into a dustbin and then the trash.
墙上挂着装裱好的照片，你以为那是曾经著名的好莱坞演员，但你认不出他们的脸，也不认识他们的名字。角落里，放着一堆老式《花花公子》杂志。你生父用一把金色的除尘刷把客人的前额和后颈扫干净，愉快地说了再见。他扫了你和康纳一眼，然后平静地走到店的后门。他消失了五秒钟，然后是10秒，15秒。他带着一把扫帚回来，缓慢地、有条不紊地把头发扫进灰尘桶，然后丢进垃圾桶。
You imagine everything leading up to this moment from his point of view. Today he woke up, probably had a coffee, kissed his wife goodbye, drove to work, attended to some regulars, made small talk about the relief of 70-degree weather or the impending invasion of Ukraine as he lined up their beards and hairlines-- took a quick lunch break, scrolled on Facebook on his phone. Ten minutes ago, he probably looked up at the clock, saw two young guys walk in, and felt a wave of relief, the last customers. As he finished sweeping the hair into a bin, he was probably hit with the feeling of relaxation that comes with knowing that the day is nearly done.
你想象着从他的角度来看导致这一刻的所有事情。今天他醒来，可能喝了杯咖啡，亲吻妻子说再见，开车上班，接待了一些常客，关于70度天气的放松或者是乌克兰即将到来的入侵闲聊，当他修剪他们的胡须和发际线时——吃了个快午餐，在手机上刷着 Facebook。十分钟前，他可能抬头看了看时钟，看到两个年轻人走了进来，感到一阵轻松，这是最后的顾客。当他把头发扫进桶里时，他可能感受到了一种因为知道一天即将结束而带来的放松感。
Now he calls those boys up to the chair. One of them, the curly-haired one who can barely look him in the eye, pulls a note from his pocket and hands it to him. His name is written on the front, and both boys walk out wordlessly. And now, what has been up until this moment a very ordinary day, has become a monumental one in just a few seconds.
现在他叫那两个男孩坐到椅子上。其中一个，那个卷发的，几乎不敢看他眼睛的家伙，从口袋里掏出一张字条递给他。他的名字写在正面，两个男孩一言不发地走了出去。现在，直到这一刻还是非常平常的一天，在短短几秒钟内变成了一个具有纪念意义的日子。
So what you just heard was made of excerpts from the first three episodes of Reaching Out. The podcast comes from Futuro and KCRW. We are right now leaving off the story in the middle of episode 3, and I really encourage you to go hear what is about to happen. Some big, big turns are right ahead. It's very satisfying.
所以你刚才听到的是《接触》前三集的摘录。这档播客来自 Futuro 和 KCRW。我们现在故事留在了第三集中间，我真的很鼓励你去听接下来会发生什么。一些重大的、重大的转折就在前方。非常令人满意。
Then, episode 4 comes out later this week, and you can actually listen to all six episodes right now if you subscribe to Futuro Plus. And if you dive in that way, maybe go back to episodes 1 and 2. They contain stuff you have not heard in our excerpts today.
然后，第四集在本周晚些时候发布，如果你订阅 Futuro Plus，你实际上现在可以收听所有六集。如果你那样潜入，也许回到第一集和第二集。它们包含了一些你今天在摘录中没听到的东西。
Reaching Out is produced, written, and sound-designed by Sayre Quevedo, editing by Maria Garcia. Music by Lucy Little, mixed by Stephanie Lebow. Executive produced by Maria Garcia and Marlon Bishop.
《接触》由塞尔·克韦多制作、撰写并负责音效设计，编辑是玛丽亚·加西亚。音乐由露西·利特尔提供，混音由斯蒂芬妮·勒博完成。执行制作人是玛丽亚·加西亚和马龙·毕晓普。
The people who put our show together today include Nadia Reiman, who produced this episode, Adriene Lilly, Tobin Low, Andrea Marks, Stowe Nelson, Ruthie Pettito, Anthony Roman, Ruby Schwartz, Lilly Sullivan, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editors are David Kestenbaum and Nancy Updike. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
今天把我们节目组合在一起的人包括纳迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman），她制作了这一集，阿德里恩·莉莉（Adriene Lilly），托宾·洛（Tobin Low），安德里亚·马克斯（Andrea Marks），斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson），鲁西·佩蒂托（Ruthie Pettito），安东尼·罗曼（Anthony Roman），鲁比·施瓦茨（Ruby Schwartz），莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan），弗朗西斯·斯旺森（Frances Swanson），克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala），朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）和黛安·吴（Diane Wu）。我们的总编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼（Sarah Abdurrahman）。我们的资深编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里（Emanuele Berry）。
And just one last reminder that we are doing a live show this Friday, coming right up October 9, and we are going to be live streaming this for all of This American Life partners. You have to be a Life Partner to see this that night. I will be telling stories on stage, and then this group of amazing comedians, convened by the very funny Vic Michaelis, are going to improvise scenes based on the stories.
最后提醒一下，我们这周五，即10月9日，有一个现场直播演出，我们将为所有《美国生活》的合伙人直播。你必须是“生活合伙人”才能在那晚看到这个。我将在舞台上讲故事，然后由非常搞笑的维克·迈克尔利斯（Vic Michaelis）召集的这群出色的喜剧演员将基于故事即兴表演场景。
We did this once before. It was really, I have to say, completely incredible. It was so fun. If you want to watch this live, sign up right now. Do not delay. Do not miss this show. It's coming right up on Friday. You can do this at ThisAmericanLife.org/lifepartners. When you do that, you'll also get access to all of our bonus episodes. You'll get ad-free listening. You get all kinds of other stuff.
我们以前做过一次。我不得不说，真的太棒了。太有趣了。如果你想观看这个直播，现在就注册。不要拖延。不要错过这场演出。它就在周五。你可以访问 ThisAmericanLife.org/lifepartners 完成注册。当你这样做时，你还将获得我们所有奖金剧集的访问权限。你将获得无广告收听。你会得到各种其他东西。
And, of course, don't just do this out of selfishness and what you get. Hopefully some part of you will take pleasure in supporting what we are doing here by helping us fund it each week. Again, ThisAmericanLife.org/lifepartners-- do it before Friday to get access to the show. That link is also in the show notes.
当然，不要只是因为自私和你能得到的东西才这样做。希望你的一部分会通过帮助我们每周为它提供资金，从支持我们在这里所做的事情中获得快乐。再次声明，ThisAmericanLife.org/lifepartners——在周五之前这样做以获得演出访问权限。该链接也在节目说明中。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, whenever he returns from lunch, this is what he says to me. I don't know what to make of it.
《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心（PRX）传递给公共广播电台。感谢一如既往的，我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生（Mr. Torey Malatia）。你知道，每次他午饭回来时，他都会这样跟我说。我不知道该怎么理解。
I'm back. Your mommy's back.
我回来了。你妈妈回来了。
Thanks, I guess? I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
谢谢，我想？我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。